Cordial greetings to all and welcome
to today's virtual seminar disorders
of the eri toy lineage of micro and
tic anemias of high prevalence in the
population
I am Cristian Leiva from Abbott Hematology
and I know your moderator for this event
today's virtual educational seminar is
presented by  the vine and brought to you
thanks to abbott diagnostics
to obtain more information about our
company you can visit the portal by the
dotcom laboratory
before starting I would like to
remind you that this event is
interactive we invite you to participate by
sending your questions at the time you
want during the  presentation for this
simply write your question in the
ask space and click on the dayz we will
answer as many questions as
time allows us at the end of the
presentation if you have
problems viewing or listening to this presentation
click on the support tab
located  at the top right
of the splash window or i
Report your problem by clicking on the
access request a question located on
the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
therefore offers continuing education credits
please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located on the top right
from the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
now I am pleased to introduce our
speaker today, Dr. Viviana
Rodríguez, who is an associate professor of
clinical hematology at the prestigious
Pontificia Universidad Javeriana in
Bogotá in Colombia. She has been working there
for  more than 20 years working
as a professor in the areas of hematology
and hemostasis and as a researcher in the
study of the microenvironment of the
human bone marrow and its relationship with the
biology of stem cells to
obtain a complete theory about
our conference access the
biography tab at  the top of your
screen
now start  We will say the presentation, I would like to
greet all those
attending this seminar, this type of virtual seminars
and not before they lived Rodríguez and
today I am going to accompany you with a
conference entitled Being of this
lineage vitro and anemia and critical of high
prevalence in
In the presentation
I want to first review the
learning objectives that I want to address. The
first of them is related to
carrying out general aspects for the
German viaticum, since the second objective is to
examine the pathophysiology of
pandemics, to deal with iron alteration
without new tests for the full
inter  initial lines by
activation of
arriving at anemias, a very frequent disorder
in the population, especially affects
progenitors and committed cells
of detroit lineage and it is clearly
demonstrated that there is no disease in
itself but rather the consequence of
facing underlying pathologies, some
of which  will be addressed are
presentation
I allow you  before starting this
talk that you will make
this point that is presented here in this
positive way
as a definition then we have
anemia as we all know that the
abnormal decrease in the
proprietary gait conventionally as the
male clip decreased
hemoglobin concentration
without alterations  morphological
secretaries clearly the most
important impact this cellular alteration that
is a decrease the optical transport box
aims the hereditary mark that
impacts at the titular level
as I mentioned before anemia
as such is not a disease it has a
consequence of different
pathologies of low
the world organization arrives  how
much the global prevalence of salt in
jazz has changed over the
years
in this objective you can see the
cover of one of the largest reports
that the
world health organization reviewed regarding the
global prevalence of anemia  this is a
multicenter study
designed by the
world health organization where it is shown that
before 1993 the etiology or the causes
of the line our population was
distributed among associated alterations
then directly killed two chronic
diseases delayed spinal cord
hemolytic anemias and existence of war
after the year 2000
The world health organization
shows that 50 percent of the
anemias that have our port are
associated with resistance yesterday followed by
inflammatory changes, but it
makes more zoo and other
Crohn's diseases
very important not to forget the
concentrations of hemoglobin to
administer to  suggestion
that the world
health organization in this report published
in 2011 also suggests that
non-pregnant women
consider that they already have a
hearing process when they have levels below
this point 9 grams per 107 grams per
liter of hemoglobin  in the case of
pregnant women levels i  Lower than
109 grams per liter and in the case of
males over 15 years of age, levels
below
9 degrees
are very important to take into account in the health organization,
but additionally there is no
conversion. These data are data that
apply to the population.  who lives at
sea level therefore we in
the study in the correlation of the
means must adjust these values
to be able to make a correct
clinical interpretation depending on the
height at which the
study population is
with these people then in this same
The 2011 report suggests a
series of adjustments that must be made to
hemoglobin concentrations
depending on the sea level institute
in which our study population is located.
As an example, I want to
refer to
the data we have in the
Colombian population only as  as an example
here
in a study that was published in
2015 it was shown that at the height of the
city d  In Bogotá,
women have a
normal life of 149 grams per
liter and men 170 grams per
liter. The city of Bogotá is located at
2,600 meters
above sea level, therefore it is
important to search this table for
adjustments of  mills the altitude at
which our patients are above
sea level as an example of drop
up to 2,600 meters in such a way that
you
being 13 grams per liter of
hemoglobin to consider that our
population really generates we
then take the reference values ​​of
our population
in this case 149 272 to be able to your
Colombian who lives in Bogotá and restores
the 13 grams per liter to define
now if the hemoglobin data that
defines the population line for
example for the drops in this case
then the women who have  levels
lower than 136 grams per liter and
men with levels
but of these 158 grams per liter at the
height of Bogotá 27 grams points  per
deciliter with patients who are
considered to already have the then very
important not to lose sight of this
we have to be the reference value of
hemoglobin concentrations of our population
that of the sea to
see individually what are the
levels of the world lives that define us
that do not define them environmental
festive amara doctor presented a
set of signs and symptoms
and require for clinical correlation to
take four
to be able to make a good analysis of
this being it is certainly not required to
know texts of the
patient's medical history family history
diet  consumption of medications and
even work activity
in the case of symptoms that are those
required by the patient we have some
symptoms like dylan and
common symptoms like dylan and
street muscle weakness and vertigo
and of course they do not correspond to the
physical examination of the patient they go  from Senegal already
mucocutaneous pallor hypotension
Congolese jaundice
neurological function it
is very important to have in context
that extinct anemic syndrome general symptoms and
signs but also
viking symptoms
and five for each type of letter
in terms of laboratory data
fundamental to evaluate all these data
that are associated with the evaluation
of the lineage the history  like the glass
cry and hemoglobin liter indices
secondary hitmen like volume
frame in half the world live with
fistula mean concentration of
hemoglobin frame medium without a doubt
the smear is in lepe de felix which is
very important the evolution of anemia
evaluate reticulocytes and other complementary tests such
as  the quantification
of 22 to 14 hydrogenated
flours and even second severity
of anemia after reaching the value of
making honey
when we talk then about the
family languages ​​can be classified from
three points
the different types of classifications
we have a classification of initial anemias
that  HE  found here on the
left side is the possibility
that corresponds to the
logical classification,
that is to say, to the vitro lineage and then from
the formal point of view with anemias it
can be magnetic lines that are rarely
seen in typical economic macro lines
that at normal level typical
happy chronic norms  and
pathogenic s amplification
we can have in the cause
beltrones to plastics also deficient
where the building impacts
vitamin b12 colist and hemolytic anemias that
can be of acquired order
we have a third and for that reason
a little in disuse since they are not
specific to the classification according to the
appearance of symptoms in anemia is
of the acute type or type 2 anemia
sensation today I am going to use
particularly the classification of
anemias from the morphological perspective and
from the ethical point of view
and we contextualize the
etiopathogenesis already appear in the different stages
by which
hematopoietic occurs we can say  go then
that plastic anemias are
social especially cellular in the
very primitive statistics with
undifferentiated affects stem cells in
the specific and average due to
today is very early anemias
where iron metabolism is altered
like the girl you bend what would it be
Necessary America especially affects
estrogen from the electronic lineage
anemia for example due to
iron deficiency and vitamin b12 forgiveness in the
midline graphically
affects hematopoietic lineages and
hemolytic anemia particularly affects
this lineage pounds and project of
course already in full stages
coaches in the stadium already
different today
we are going to work particularly on the
miter line typical
effect on the identification of firewood they
crucify me in the scientific literature
many algorithms to which you can
access and in the majority
that was the option of anemias should
begin with an assessment of the
different  beings users of various
marketing with happier rubin and tarja
and the exploration of precisely
sad blood from these two
initial parameters that are the ones that later
end up in the initial part of this
algorithm then we can decide if
we have red blood cells with a
particular volume  medium minor 80 liter field in
which case we would be talking about chronic
microphysical team anemia families
of high prevalence in the
population are those that involve to a
large extent alterations in the
metabolism of the son-in-law and previously
like this long conquest that
led the  burning report and also
health days where 50 percent
of anemias represent the population
is involved at the end of the
war metabolism marbles
when we talk about changes in
iron metabolism and its contribution
with specific economics we have
both scenarios  anemia where forgive
decreased
spheroidal iron levels  Rich where we find iron deficiency anemia,
anemia followed by technique and
the secondary measurement of inflammation and
we have the other scenario where the
patient has anemia but the
increase in iron levels in
which case we are talking about anemia
and doubling
particularly of anemias and
specific  6 or chronic where the
levels of
iron significantly
or iron deficiency anemia or
that of I cling to parakeet or as it was
known in the last century but yes with
the green terminal it is a pathology that
has been described in very old texts
inscribed in the party  which dates from the year
1500 before Christ and presents itself to a
siege, a series of signs and
symptoms very similar to those that 300
patients with iron deficiency anemia are indicated,
however, it is really the doctor
Tomás Tejas who initially
speaks of the pathology and because it is
stable  disease can be treated with
iron salts and that patients
can respond very well to iron salts
at present.  ality also as a
proposal of the
world health organization and different
scientific literature it is known that iron
deficiency anemia is an anemia and of multiple etiology
the slow onset of apprehension
multifactorial biology corresponds to the
presence of demographic factors
you can see here on the
side  on the right of the slide these
demographic factors are with the
population at risk where we find
girls
later adolescents pregnant women
displaced migrants
and these demographic factors
who additionally nutritional factors such
as poor nutrition
high in fat excessive consumption of
coffee and you
generate greater well-being at the level of the
country and they say among these
demographic and nutritional factors we add
social and psychological factors such as
conditions of poverty alcohol abuse
gastrointestinal disorders and chronic bleeding
with this scenario then the patient
will have a very high risk of developing  ar
a girl but
in general the signs and symptoms that are
associated with specific and not very comical aleñas,
particularly iron deficiency anemia,
are varied, among them
are the pica syndrome that is
observed with some frequency in
our children in Latin America
this sensation that they think about  consume
products or substances that are not
food such as earth such as lime
as it seems that it is a kind
of clay preparation with
which women of the state are made it
has
types of non-food substances as
a way of answering
the mineral I knew it little endemic that
It also enhances iron
deficiency anemia these deformities
the nails that patients present
this manifests angular that does not
and breaks but observes
occasional and spatial pathologies
impossible
in general this accompanied by the exit
of the subway that is planned is part of the
destination magic was tempted related
by deficiency anemia and it is
from the point of view of the  laboratory
percent
to the conventional tests of
hematocrit and hemoglobin plus electrical
arias it
is necessary secondary
you want to perform the tests called
I have had those that are part of the
textile
in the iron profile we find
then chili
or how iron levels credit
can be evaluated by different  tests
colors and
lettering is the france fight subject
proteins iron carrier that
can also be carried by different
tests and three lists of lomé trias there is
the percentage of
transferrin extraction that corresponds more to a
kyle knowing
l
for the explanatory capacity of the
two towers
remember that the explanation capacity
of the transferred is inversely
proportional to the
historical iron levels, the higher the lower levels
and the lower the levels of the
parakeet error, we will have
additionally higher levels in this weight of
food than  recipe calculation is
whatever is  less than me it did not let me
quantify it is refined close very
important the person close we will
talk about them
later it is calculated that a nanogram
of ferritin close reflects 8 milligrams
of iron stored in an extra
security way this ferritin explained that the
volume therefore  We can
perfectly quantify the plasma
by different tests of lomé trias
certainly try the micro and clean
and we have three staining bands
specifically to detect
intracellular iron levels
like women and which can be
started through for issues such
as attention to
there  variable variables
by the aid generated by the
creator of saints have alteration in the
metabolism of the day
when we speak then of the
hill line allow remembering that it is a
pathology with a multifactorial etiology it
is of slow appearance of
internal appearance it is
considered a  disease that can
become chronic
due to its effect russia sociolo  gy we talk
about different stages of development of
iron deficiency anemia according to
laboratory variables so in
this positive on the left side
you can see the different
laboratory parameters with which you
can categorize the stage in
which the patient you are testing to
develop is  in that localism we
then have from the primary hematocrit and
hemoglobin recognizing the reds and the
secondary but without making it very important here
in a matter of those transferred 6
then fibrin as such and the
morphology and troy that we have to
be monitoring through the project
the  The first stage of development, then,
is the reflection of the trip, although the
patient as such has a better offer, it
begins with the process of reflection of
iron that, without a doubt, the activist with the
decrease in stored iron deposits
and also at the medullary level in this
first stage.  where is iron bending
slightly
the prima  and secondary
but more dramatically the first thing that
decreases with external levels
is a form of
fat-soluble iron storage to be
used
immediately gdp levels start to
rise slightly the epidemic may
be normal we can have
but iron levels that  They may
still be normal and there it becomes
important then the fertile ones
because Argentina is a variable that
has to do with a very rapid
premature birth
and what
in Europe
the enjoyment of peripheral blood we are going to
see red without any selection by itself
and the patient does not revert  the causes that
produce this disease go to the
next stage so that
erythropoiesis
here has already exhausted an
important part of the
available iron
but here at this stage we are capturing
alterations in the principles of
simplicity is primary secondary a
decrease much more  marked in the
theoretical fertile levels an
increase  to moderate in what
and already a definition of
spherical iron levels with these milestones
light moderate and also light
again if it is not reversed but
you treat the patient and patient continues
in the evolution process for the
next stage
as the line  20 p
the girl to do technique then already
presents very decreased primary cited liter indices
very decreased secondary indices in
the retina effect is dedicated that are
below 5 nanograms per milliliter
we already have
high with low levels
but this is not again what the
This is
inversely proportional to the thousand
times the CPI, well, the peripheral protests,
and we are going to see
more
marked alterations in taking steroids with an
anesthetist, a marked dose with the presence
of micros and cough, a possible
marked situation with different formats and troy
of no economy, it is also
important.  remember in the
conventional iron deficiency girl that this
pathology
this story that  and it is appreciated that they do not
prosper conventionally
necessary in the project of blood and
felipe
additional to this line nor specific and
electrochromic where the definition
of iron levels is proportional
iron deficiency anemia as such the
different
multifactorial agents we are now going to talk about
secondary firewood  inflammation that is
also framed in the context of a
line where decreased
iron levels but whose cause in the
decreased iron is different
in this secondary girl inflammation
is very important
during the inflammatory process among
them the most important present
destined that we have
66 its effect on the
at different levels is known but because you
do not feel today being and exposed and
6-2
this increase in the signal for the
deposits to produce a protein that is
called
when patients have high
levels of pity 366 in  a network of
current what you think that expresses the
hepatocytes sends  a cellular purpose
correntada to the deposits where the
pollination of
transcription factors in these the different
factors of dogs to these factors
behind will make it from the nucleus of the hepatocyte
and induce the transmission izar pro the gene
amp this gene encodes for a
protein called  ectv
in such a way that leptin levels
assists inflammatory processes with
directly proportional to
sterile levels the more
inflammatory costs more intestinal 6 in the
patient increases significantly it
is a protein under normal conditions
that helps iron homeostasis
It largely controls the absorption of
intestinal iron and largely controls
the use of iron
in this step in the skin
, however, when
its levels are significantly reduced, it is already divine
what ferroportin is, a protein
that allows iron to escape.
assigned among hepatic villars
also
and in intestinal cells the spine
blocks the protein in president its
internalization and degradation in such a
way that the iron stored in more
all
and
it through the diet that is
extended from the duodenal xl cannot be
used you cannot face these
cells that were retained
in this place does not come out  blood and then
because it generates a decrease in the
epidemic
in the acceleration of erythropoiesis
due to the development scams that are
observed in the iron deficiency girl in the
stocking will hang in flames are
we can also identify the advantages of the
process according to laboratory parameters
starting from  the same variables
indices and owners primary
secondary terms of view 6 times
live and morphology of 'destroyed' is the
first joint stage of the
inflammatory process that drives this
implements
when
iron levels increase and iron levels drop
and so on until success  political is
occurring in the midst of abortion as he
came down to close a  extraction
happy estimated in the secondary but
the very important impact on the partridge
inah of opponents occurred in the
line due to iron resistance of the
secondary girl information the
relevant levels have increased because the sentence
also considers an acute phase protein
that increases the building  amatory
under this context ferritin then
loses the value of
prematurely verifying an angel process the
patient also increases three in this
iron levels can be bad
in which it can be very bad let's
be patient move on to the next stage
where there is a  sustained increase
in stress levels let's go by then
alterations in which
several secondary stress are needed in a
much more marked way again
the terika retinas also
increase plp they
want before we will see some
light moderate
mortal alterations since it prohibits  associated with
mitosis that was advertised
if  the patient finally advances
continues in this process of joy
second broader inheritance there is no
iron protection
there is nowhere to take it from and iron is all
the cells of the epithelium of the line 4
foci of esparteros hispanic and there
then we are going to see a much larger dimension
the most dramatic of the primary
activities peric lloyd is a
very marked increase in the retinas with a
very important increase of 3
and already all the pathological morphology to the
present without marked
and marked and one could leave again
celestial foundations and need me
here very important not to forget  a
specific girl has a team soon secondary
isolation these levels of their retinas
hovers their value
since the levels compensate and it loses
completely because the devil ours
early we had previously spoken to you it
is very important to remember that
ferritin is undoubtedly a parameter that
has advantages  Because it reflects success
, something is used with respect to iron, which
is very i  It is important, but the great
advantages it has is that if a
starting protein and when these people
have anemia affects the metabolism on a
daily basis and also and owners,
this variable loses its validity,
however this year
the World Health Organization
published this year  a guide on how to
interpret
in patients who have
inflammatory processes 7 effects
in an early bale test
global early diagnosis of health in this guide was
published in 2020 they suggest
that in order to use the values ​​of
this routine in a variable that there is
Now the diagnosis of anemia must be
considered at a
different level than the patient is or is not
in an inflammatory process.
For example, for me it gives me three things that I
consider to be lower levels than serious outbreaks,
then grams per liter as an
ideal barrier of interesting
early prognosis
in preschool.  It presents with an
inflammatory process at levels of 12
grams of liter
and mysterious  s not active and we have to
use 30 as the cut-off point
at present, 30 micrograms per liter,
consider it because in this story they were
followed on the
health side because they imply that there has been
using serum ferritin
levels with a variable that can
release anemia but
up to  different values ​​the present
is happening
simultaneously with this story
even in this scenario the stubborn one is
this
and to
foresee and it will really give us the
information that is required for more
premature
under this context then there are
other parameters that can
replace these levels of service
America that can be used to
monitor and adhere to treatment in
patients with children and that is done with
chronic iron metabolism-associated
time to do treatment in
signing can also act as a
very central prognostic value
indicate since the disease there
then in these parameters  Today
we talk about reticulum hemoglobin  or
necessary
of reticulocytes
and the very interesting soluble receptor to
transfer here in this life is positive
you can observe the different
tibias need to pay to name these
variables others are different
physically automated when we talk about
hemoglobin articles italy because
we are talking about the hemoglobin
that the resistant ones have  and cough
this foundation is prohibited through
automated equipment
to evaluate not only size and
complexity
in quantifying hemoglobin articles
itary
we have the moment that the
physical or love literature of linares costs me but
citing that it
is in ruins allows us to evaluate the
availability of  iron that exists in
the bone marrow and increases between 48
and 72 hours later
also try that if we all
evaluate in a patient who has a
line by the iron system that is
responding very quickly to the
treatment evaluating instead of a
sudden
we have then  that the reticulum already tells us to
cite
to increase response to treatment
because the mind is so earthly
hemorrhagic and secondary recordings are reduced to me
, which serves
to replace conventional magazines,
they are also decreased by
aligning themselves before training and there are
different reference ranges, values
of  reference to the offer for
technology, for example, in the limit and
the values ​​of the reference range for
the western university
5.3 and 35.5 picograms, let us remember that
although these ranges exist, their
reference values ​​suggest depending
on the part of the energy, we
have the reference values ​​of
our
population according to our
geographic songs diets
impressions sciences varies according to
these different genetic positions
that rafael
conditions that make the population
have a relatively sad behavior
there dances the deficient hemoglobin
as an option to replace these
cuts  inas perica in the study the
commitment of laterals to the same
iron is also a leader
with maturity I repeat the eye
for it will put the evaluation in the
recognized group that values ​​the articles that
have the highest content of rené a
of course an evaluation that we cannot
de  In an optical way, we cannot do it
conventionally because it is very difficult to
differentiate between psychological with high
because René Alberto would be that he has a
low
for this reason the invalid fraction
requirements crimes with the highest
content of hostages are evaluated with him
the order here in which left state
In the lower left part of the
objective area, different colors are observed. It
is that they are immobilizing
in recent years, as in the final orange,
now undermined.
difference the amount
of relaxation
important to remember that manual counting
and  There
is proof that the usual errors
that some manual methodologies have
when mounting high counts the
coefficient of variation in
manual counts is also 16% but
when we talk to a patient with
reticulocytes
in the reticulum there are low but
demanding several companies use
this 30+  %
then they have three the indication is
that we know these reticulocyte counts
are linked to automated methodologies that transmit us normal meridian distances of reticulocytes verses of titles and clubs that are macy's inc
and when we are talking about manual techniques
very well similar air also occurs  with
the absolute counts that sometimes
later in a good sensitivity but
sometimes finding esteem then it is
important
for him
now these say later in this
record the success
we then have milestone articles with
high although actually with an intermediate size
with a low content
in  the fraction and maturity of the  s milestones well
clearly that they have a high
content of rn to this formation to see
if you see according to each technology
accordion rod to each technology
but important
and fiscal that the mature pressure to
receive success measurements of the
delegation of the team of time are added
a lot because the immature fraction
reticulocytes
and appears earlier than the
same total population of records and
it is also a sad sight for us
already a cell regeneration a
restoration in laser and
tractor troy article quoted between 5 and 7 days
the treatment of its 2 to  15 days
the reticulocyte count is total
then the fraction in adore you
successfully already behaves with an
early marker for bone marrow
transplantation or rapid bone marrow regeneration
also to look at
what you have inserted and from this function
before
screaming we will start from  a grid to
already cite in it the victory of treatment with
various such as those that summon us
today not  However, Ronald and
hemorrhages, this abyss fills
negative lines between patients,
the reference values,
visions of ranges, a little according to
technology in the initial case, but he
finally answered, we have the soluble receptor
of Franz Ferdinand, which I consider,
we have here a very
interesting potential for  anemia is a variable
that has not been used
yet, it is valid but it has a
very interesting potential.
I was going for certain pieces that are in
the microenvironment of the bone marrow in
such a way that we can
classify this 3
3 separately I invite you to victory
with that we can find in
peripheral blood that is
proportional to the number of cells the
stress that they are  in the world and it has been
shown that these common receptors
of transferred or the molecule d  e 72
honors increases in firewood
if it seems to increase the
compensation mechanism for these dysfunctions of the
hustle and bustle that is occurring as for your
account of the deficit the money is very
interesting and they are not used
decreases
renán there was
the law
valencia- nation in terms of
peripheral foses does not have the pp,
so it is very important to always
use these other
iron parameters with which we have been
working today and usually
consider parameters such as the world and
the ecological network arias in the
milestone articles and are only provided in  terms
of peripheral blood smear is
present and you see on the
right side it
is frequent that the red blood cells present a
marked district
presence of liters filters the
economy brand equipment and it is not usual to
find centers
the term of the white blood cells
are generally normal  where of
morphologies but the recipes
can register high levels
we can  We have patients with thrombosis,
all in the iron mine.
In the second group of
micro-typical or chronic alterations or allergies of
high prevalence in the population, we have
the European Extension Agency, which is
where we observed the increase in
videos, would you tell them,
in this context, we are talking  So from
the families it has doubles
, you know, it's from the Costa Ricans, they also have
different presentations, there is a need to move away
from genetic type plastics of this
dance, the energy of the Costa Ricans of
acquired order and even so, it had been particularly secondary plastic arts,
that's how it is
between the white sandals with people.
For example, there is the stone that is
linked as a demonstration of
which the first
one of the smallest associated with the
early consumption of alcohol in Beijing
and in the secondary school doing in the
plastic video we then have, for example,
half a refractory girl with whom
at night
in  the context of the whole process that
leads to the synthesis of the group of
mossos we have then  s here is also
the current of the enzyme of the path
where the only one always is so that this
is activated with which all the
companies of the group of dying the sesto
plasma start and then continue the entire
production process of the group
of mitochondrial manuel the  program
we have the alignment of doing cases of
alcoholism where it is shown that
chronic consumption before electricity alters the
function of above like 1 per phil and
the room itself is no longer enough to do it
and additionally we have for example
refractory firewood met loops in
rings where  It is also somewhat associated with
some performance of the mitochondria
that leads to a previous
active oxidation system
in a similar way as we have
discussed today with respect to anemia
because iron is used in secondary anemia
the inflammation in the girl
has  you fold and here there is also the series
of stages of development that we can
fun
the laboratory tests we have in
Then a first stage where there is a
lot of iron encouraging success but
it can no longer be
like the poem
the process of elevation
by speculating there is no alteration of love anymore the
whole territory we are going to have
a regression and deficient and we are going to
have a line I want  plastic as such
established where here in Jerez for in
these most important are the
iron levels which sent messages increasing I
had fun easy that is advancing in this
line of doubling
from the morphological point of view the
measurements I want practice we are going to
find the three  be again the
chronic reds and geophysicists
with mikel or moderate
who are compromised that are
advanced billing of the patient
is bone marrow we can see and
outline our mentors electrons in
peripheral blood and we hope to find
depository situations the
geographical line is characterized by 11 reds
they can get to have point of the close
and characteristic bodies of the paper
cr  istal three deposits of micros
you would put with a content in
Madrid in a pot additionally
we can find them for our
clients expenses
the ring many of them wills
progenitors electors with an
abnormal iron content that can be
elucidated through extinctions as they
make this
as a conclusion  point 11 between this
section of today in which we have
spoken and the specific
economic families where
iron metabolism impacts we can say that the girl due to
iron deficiency anemia iron deficiency the one
with high prevalence in the world population
the inflammatory processes but the
development  of miami specifies the
commitment
the quantification of its medical office
allows the early diagnosis and easy
to take lines to use then
the differential diagnosis between lines
but péric to the line second inheritance
more network has the determination of new
hematological parameters such as urine
resists bidding now  by  mature action
are letters terrine of 75 clouds and the
bees I want to spend more frequent are
decisions and these are with the
chronic consumption of alcohol and medication
with this part of constructions we
finished this section of today
was then pending from
this moment of  Any questions that
you want to ask, all
clear, thank you very much for your attention,
stay here to have an assistant. We
appreciate the presentation of
Viviana Rodríguez's tutor and we start the
round of live questions and answers
about this virtual seminar
again if you have any questions at
our speaker please send it
now simply click on the
ask a question link which is located on
the far left of your
screen doctor viviana will answer as many
questions as the remaining time allows
doctor viviana let's start with
a first question
that you suggest then
preferably evaluate the immature fraction of
reti  culocytes instead of performing a
total reticulocyte count in the
evaluation of early erythropoiesis
in response to treatment,
the greeting ran again for all
those attending this academic event and
if indeed in the context of this
detection of this new population
within the report  of reticulocytes and
much more of tips to evaluate this
transformative I repeat successes of tower
title always fernando content of rn
since it gives us an
earlier measure that he has also answered in
the
perfect contract doctor a next question
because cytokine levels are not quantified
proinflammatory as
diagnostic parameters for anemia
due to inflammation
well this is a very
interesting question in fact there are many
laboratory strategies to
quantify cytokines but
unfortunately many of them are not
clinically validated we use them and research
but many of them are not formality  is
infinite and that there are tests to
quantify
by means of antibodies studied to
quantify these cytokines surely
and it is a problem and also a bit of the
subject of things, therefore in great freedom
to write to evaluate the molecules
as a consequence of these elevations
of cytokines such as those of lower pinto
So it's a bit of a
fun topic to get a little closer to the
cost of
the tests on the rod. This
was seductive. We have another question here,
what are the pre-
analytical conditions that 50 must have for the
measurement of ferritin,
very important, these questions,
YouTube,  fasting it is important that the
patient have at least a
12-hour fast so that
small functions in the mind of their
proper iron deposits do not interfere and today a
very important issue is also being refined is
quantified prudent conscious
after the  patient has been
committed some type of restrictions
have to take a time of various  It's been
weeks before it can really get
complicated, it's soon, a
reliable university and something similar happens with the
treatment with iron, maybe
ferrous people are not in an active project
of pertinent González closed because it
can also impact the
blind levels refining
perfect doctor here is a  next
question how these issues that
you told us are associated
with patient is kobe 19
very very interesting extremely
interesting infection processes such
as these infect society shark
points
know that they directly affect
erythrocytes without the erythrocytes
having the reflectors of the
converting enzyme  I ask you to make use of the
service they have above but if the
disciplines that recovered storms you
investigate the infected patients
greatly affect the successes and
I accepted the success entering but never
seen it
is a new term where the cells
see as much as the phrases  of the life
given to him by the patients he is  n
infected
perfect cultural we have the option for
a one last question I have here
one that comes
quite far from Peru they ask us
can reticulum hemoglobin be used
as a marker in the evolution
of a neoplasm whatever the type
[Music]
let's say directly with
Troy's lineage,
if we are facing acute-chronic plaques,
interprets the
reports, for example, here he would have to
associate very well, he is very clean,
because if he is a patient who is
wanting a process where he sends this,
all the infiltration is being generated  of
metal and there is an affectation of the trip
of this type there are videos
this proliferation can be affected by the blasters
due to this type of reports
the terminal problems are moving arts times
that the comics plant goes down but
make a patient who is
undergoing treatment for this collision well
here it is  as the variables
could be accepted as specific to our
association due to the great diversity  ad
thank us that there are, for example, of
logical order the farms that have been reported
recently or the bad prognosis
then it is a type of association and I would
specifically recommend to
move in more speed
a little rather to the late parameters
suggested by the mint and the  different
international powers but
dignify this neoplasia in the light
also of the concepts and by the
recommendations of the procedures of
good to the prognosis say the typical
aberrant imitations
there are a series of evaluations by
order specific forms to circumvent
with a parameter the lineage destroy
thanks normally  Dr. Viviana for
her presentation and kindness in
responding to these questions, we
would also like to thank Aurich and our
sponsor Abbott Diagnostics for
signing up
for today's educational webinar before we leave, we want to
thank the audience for joining us
today and all their active participation.  the
questions what  If we didn't have time to
respond you will be approached by our
speaker to submit responses
to the contact information you
provided at the time you submitted
your question
this webinar will be viewable on
demand for the next six months
labruce will email you
when  is available
for reproduction we invite you to
share this message with your colleagues
who might have missed the event
and today thank you very much for your assistance and
until next time
goodbye